pas la nuit tombe sur l'ancienne abbaye
de marmoutier et les futurs
investisseurs arrivent c'est
particulièrement généreux avec nous et
donc merci beaucoup
j'ai lâché
merci c'est ce qu'on appelle un
partenariat solide
après avoir installé un gigantesque parc
de loisirs dans la forêt de brocéliande
et sur le théâtre antique de lyon un
nouveau projet doit voir le jour sur ce
site historique du bord de loire le
futur hipark à bastia tous les moyens
sont bons pour le directeur la tâche et
de communication et la comptable pour
tenter de convaincre vos déambulations
chant musique permettent aux partenaires
de se faire leur propre opinion imaginer
les bâtiments s'étaler de l'arrière du
repos saint martin jusqu'à la maison du
fonds regardez il s'agit de trois
comédiens de la compagnie alborada une
création inédite une visite spectacle à
travers un lieu de mémoire qui permet
aux visiteurs de découvrir ou
redécouvrir ce lieu fondé par saint
martin au 4e siècle n'a passé un très
bon moment avec avec la troupe et puis
ça nous a permis de découvrir le site
j'étais déjà venu visiter les fouilles
au moment de d'une journée du patrimoine
mais c'est toujours avec plaisir qu'on
revient sur le site de noirmoutier c'est
décalé c'est drôle il ya plein de
chansons des musiques et en même temps
un texte patrimoniale de fond très
intéressant donc je pense que pour les
personnes qui connaissent pas forcément
le site c'est déjà une bonne entrée en
matière pour les découvrir
futur projet comporte la construction
d'une brasserie une tyrolienne ou encore
un centre nautique une fois exposé les
investisseurs d'un soir doivent faire un
choix du futur parc à bastia est
maintenant entre vos mains
le public était amené à voter pour ou
contre ce projet puisqu'il a tous les
éléments en main pour boule blanche le
projet soit massivement contre boule
noire le projet et du coup la fin sera
différente d'une soirée à l'autre
résultat de ce vote alors le parc
d'attractions verra-t-il le jour à vous
de choisir
neuf autres représentations ont lieu
jusqu'au 25 août